[Musique]
il était une fois une île grande comme
un canton de chine rocher rose dans la
vaste méditerranée elle n'était pas
jalouse de ses deux grandes voisines
majorque et minorque
elle conservait dans ses ruelles
éclatante de lumière un air de modestie
charmante et de joie de vivre
7 il existe toujours et elle n'a point
changé c'est ibiza perles des balais à
la vie coule lentement à l'heure
espagnole entre les murs des pâtures
nombreux dans le champ des fresh
fontaine les enfants d'ibiza comme ceux
du pirée rêve de lointains continent
quand ils seront plus grands ils iront
sur la mer dans la barque paternel et
pêcheurs de lune aux nuits du plein été
jetteront dans les flots leurs songes et
leurs filets
[Musique]